[Music]
Jacob is with us in Florida hi Jacob
welcome to the Dave Ramsey show hey Dave
thanks for taking my call we sure did
what's up you know a BA
two quick questions hopefully can get to
the quick this one is on my life my 31
years old and my question is should I
sell my tax be shuttered sediment for
lump sum of 2 point 1 million dollars to
pay off debt and invest the rest for
retirement in the world that you get a
tax-free settlement that size for that's
the question is it still wrongful death
situation my mother had passed away
years years ago so just something that I
know considered pretty yeah so they are
paying you in X number of dollars over a
long number of years that amounts to a
total of 20 million dollars and you can
sell they sell it for two million or
something like that
yeah the aggregated about six million
today
it sold until 2060 at $1 of 2060 and
then it all ourselves day the cash value
about 2.1 million somebody's trying to
see if we really just want to set up for
retirement and see like the plumbing of
course
what I would tell you to do is to sit
down with a financial adviser if you
don't have one click smart Wester Dave
Ramsey comm one of our smart investor
pros can sit down help you calculate
this and your you can figure out what
the discount rate is meaning what
interest rate they have used to
calculate the the net of 2.1 as a
settlement offer on this and then you
can determine can you invest and make
similar rates of return or better rates
of return I would rather have the money
in your hands and have it invested and
of course you will need that free in the
process too and you've also freed up
your income so I like the idea of taking
it I just don't know how deeply they're
discounting the net present value of
this and that's what this offer is based
on it's a financial formula and so you
need someone to sit down and calculate
it and if they say your discount rate on
this thing is 20% then someone's trying
to slay you you know in other words
they're they're using a 20 percent rate
of return to the
terminus value and that would be crazy
you would want a lower discount rate
which would give you a higher settlement
amount then in this situation so I don't
know who's offering to buy this whether
it's the existing annuities getting
ready we'll sell it out for that but you
need to get into it and figure out what
the figures are and that will tell you
whether to take the offer but if it's a
decent offer on the discount rate I'm
out of there I'm taking my cash being
debt-free I'm gonna invest my cash I'm
gonna be back in control of all this
money Wow what a deal